but when you're covering a war you have
to go to places where you could be
killed or where others are being killed
yeah yeah for that and put one foot in
front of the other no matter how afraid
you are to make that suffering part of
the record
is it safe obviously to walk what did
this well need they said she's healing
this one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen foreign
correspondent of the year Murray :
[Applause]
did you like that at Treasure Island
I need a photographer any good the best
I'm still thinking about it unless you
go crazy it's not something you get used
to or is not so terrible for governments
for they are not wounded or killed like
ordinary people our mission is to speak
the truth to power
we're prepared to thank your country in
the Civil War
what happened they've opened fire on
journalists if the government catches
you they'll kill you I have nightmares
every night
you see more war than most holders you
have to take it seriously
I hate being in a war zone I also feel
compelled to see it for myself because
you're addicted to it
if you use the stuff from those drones
will know where we are don't have fun no
one in their right mind would do what do
you do
she needs to get the hell out of it
[Music]
we have to go back we will die if we go
back
I want people to know your story you
have a god-given talent for making
people stop and care
to being alive I see it so you don't
have to take if you raise your
conviction
what hope do the rest of us have maybe I
would have liked a more normal life
maybe I just don't know how
you